65 7 % d'abstention au second tour des
dernières régionales
un chiffre préoccupant une table ronde a
donc été organisée mardi 18 janvier au x
campus à saint-germain-en-laye qu'un
vrai sujet abstention et qu'il faut
absolument affronter puisque ça indique
à malaise dans notre démocratie élus
locaux citoyens et spécialistes ont
cherché des solutions pour inciter au
vote véritablement se pose la question
du sens quel sens cela at-il à des voté
pour quoi allons nous voter par exemple
c'est pas évident pour les régionales et
départementales
parce qu'on comprend pas quel est le
rôle de ces instructions comprendre le
partage des compétences et pour ça il
faut avoir une meilleure éducation et je
crois que c'était un point très
important que ce soit une meilleure
éducation à la citoyenneté et ça se fait
dès l'école dès l'école primaire il
faudrait donc éduquer mais aussi
simplifier c'est surtout la
compréhension fine plus fine des
institutions du rôle de chacun une
simplification qui me semble ressortir
des attentes des citoyens ce soir dans
l'assistance les personnes présentes
prenait part au débat l'initiative a été
bien accueillie je pense que c'est à
renouveler je continue à travailler sur
ce sur ses talons si on veut changer la
situation je sais que les jeunes sont
évidemment très occupée par l'abstention
après moi je sais que c'est un jeune
assez politisé donc je venais pas
vraiment pour moi mais bon c'était aussi
pour savoir pour en apprendre plus c'est
l'élection présidentielle résistent
encore à l'abstention en 2017 elle
s'élevait à 25 % au second tour la
prochaine aura lieu en avril